For Alan, hanging up the Chinese character
for double happiness is an ironic gesture.
It’s usually reserved for newly weds, but
Alan is single -- and she doesn’t want to
be a wife.
What she does want is to be a mother.
"I've wanted to have a baby my whole adult
life.
I want to be a mother and as a woman I want
to experience getting pregnant and giving
birth."
Alan has petitioned delegates of the National
People's Congress, China's Parliament, asking
that single women be given access to sperm
banks -- a taboo in China, where family planning
authorities can still fine unmarried mothers
for unsanctioned babies.
She’s realistic about her chances of immediate
success.
"Getting access to artificial reproduction
technology as an unmarried woman is certainly
going to very difficult.
But I think some time in the very, very distant
future, it will be possible."
Alan, not her real name, has talked about
her yearning for motherhood on social media.
Her posts have sparked a lively debate in
a society where traditional family values
still rule.
In a park in Beijing, parents gather on Sundays
to lay out their children’s resumes for
prospective partners.
An unmarried child can stigmatize the whole
family.
Women in particular are under huge pressure
to marry by their late twenties.
"Marriage in China is an arrangement between
families.
Everything that happens in that marriage becomes
the business of the couple’s parents and
extended family.
But I want a relationship where two people
decide for themselves whether they want to
be together, how to live and whether they
want children."
Alan known those aspirations won’t make
it easy to find a partner.
So she's now looking for a sperm donor online.
Currently, she holds down three different
jobs in the creative industry.
She belongs to China's "me' generation" -- those
born after 1990 and often considered more
individualistic and demanding.
"Our generation's ideas about marriage and
childbirth are very far away from the previous
generations.
Most people don’t discuss these issues.
But if you look at their behavior, there is
a clear message: And that message is that
our generation is less ready to compromise
and wants to have more personal choices."
Alan says she would love to find a father
who would take care of the child, without
the expectations of a traditional family.
But if that doesn’t work out, she is willing
to go it all alone.